[Music]
live from the Jon Lovitz podcast theatre
it's Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman
[Music]
is Friday night in Hollywood so let's
babble the [ __ ] on I'm Kevin Smith
and I'm Ralph Garman yes you are very
kind to come out on a Friday night after
a long day of work I'll do you one
better than that this is a I can set
this to you in a while
we're sold out tonight sir what
wall-to-wall we are sold out and now
we've lost half the crowd just the ones
wearing helmets how are you doing sir it
is Friday we rarely get to do it on
Friday night a Friday night feels nice
but I like being here how are you I'm
doing well how about yourself
excellent I'm sure you've got some
shoutouts and [ __ ] you want to read we
do we start off every show with shout
outs of people who came particularly
long distances or celebrating special
occasions so I want to get to it and we
have a new shout out jingle for this
portion you know we come last week we
discovered it last week so let's kick
things off it's a shout out Kevin at
Brown so get your [ __ ] out
did you [ __ ] out I still don't
understand it but the people seem to
love that's how I feel on a Friday night
man once again a management has asked me
to repeat we don't want you to take that
literally some of the gentleman the
audience took liberties last week when
they said get your [ __ ] out okay really
there were some [ __ ] the management
says no but Hollywood babble-on says yes
whoever wants to slap it on the desk
come on up just save that for after the
show that jingle by the way from James
Thompson from Manchester England I
wanted to give him the last time I'm
gonna mention that city because you do
that every time
first shout out is his ball excuse me
Paul Gerald's in the audience holy [ __ ]
Paul jor-el you got off Krypton
[ __ ] oh it's it's Gerald's
darrell's he's gonna like oh I thought
you were the Krypton hells yeah parents
put him in a small spaceship when he was
a lad and no he's just like [ __ ] the kid
I'm getting in that spaceship for my
birthday my wife Denise got me tickets
for your Friday show she claims she got
his tickets because she knows what a
huge fan I am and that's not just a fat
joke at my expense Paul writes she guys
tickets for her own selfish reasons my
wife has had the hots for Ralph since
the Joe Schmo show is your wife up there
Paul
well hello Paul's wife so get your [ __ ]
yeah
that's long maybe prophetic and
prophylactic I hope we used to have the
greatest bedroom rumps after every
episode I swear I kept many of those
episodes on TV
TiVo just to use as porn small rights my
goodness Friday 3-way I'm hoping at the
end of tonight's show I'll get to return
to the glorious lap of luxury since I'm
pretty sure she'll be good to go by the
show's end if it's not too much to ask
can you please convince her to give up
the balloon knot in your Harrison Ford
voice as long as I'm getting some I'm
cool with her imagining I'm you for the
night all right
you do that you like pretend I'm Garmin
[Music]
KY jelly and i'ma first
there you go Paul good luck tonight
how about Nick and Eddie Nick and Eddie
you in the crowds tonight
hello boys Nick Eddie right Eddie
hey you're throwing Nick and Eddie
what's that my friend Eddie and I will
be on the crowd on July 8th so can you
please tell us tell us one of your Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] jokes in your edwin voice
that would make our night
well remind me at the end of the show
when we do that and i will do that for
you I feel bad because Nick and Eddie
right since we're 20 years old we can't
buy drinks you guys you guys have to sit
through this [ __ ] sober I feel bad we
don't even sit through this shit's over
so high yeah so drunk really so you they
let the men if you can't drink it's 18
or over here really yeah man so weird it
must be like going to an orgy and every
time you go to touch like no no no no
you wearing a chastity belt to an orgy
how about Melissa Melissa see you in the
crowd from Knoxville Tennessee you hear
Melissa well [ __ ] you Melissa you don't
get your email read man it's just that
simple
how about the John Hewitt Johnny you
hear from Australia from Melbourne
Australia where there you are John was
here last week with his his girlfriend
it was her first day in town right you
guys came here to see the show is that
it was update yeah so you were here last
time well and more where do you hear
this so my girlfriend and I came to HBO
last week the day she arrived in town
from Melbourne well you were kind enough
to give us a shout out which made are
very happy we enjoyed the show and the
Lovitz Club so much that we came back
the next day to see the ABCs of SNL that
you did with John left right on man
before the show started our waitress
came to take our order and believe it or
not was able to remember exactly what we
had ordered the night before where
everybody knows your name
of the hundreds of people that came to
the club in those two days how was she
able to remember our order my girlfriend
Sarah is convinced it means that the
waitress wishes to engage in a threesome
with us which Sarah is enthusiastic
about we are hoping you can ask the
waitress tonight whose name was Ashley
whether this is a fact this in fact is
what she wants we'll be at the show
which you could tell us what she said
thanks a million John Hewitt Ashley are
you in there you around the house
tonight Ashley where are you Ashley
hey Ashley did you want to have a
threesome with this couple right here
no I'm okay thank you she said it's a
polite rejection she said she said she'd
have the same percentage in three-way
she'd have with them that they left as a
tip nine percent just a little bit yeah
our podcast to get creepy three ways
yeah that's what we use the podcast yeah
really
what's your safe word for this week
liver mine's kangaroo is really an honor
of the wild [ __ ] noises coming from
the room or wherever wrong way and
like a didgeridoo exactly and then I'll
sit you here since this [ __ ] fat
voice screaming come knock on the door
that's not a position is it no that's me
realizing what a bad idea it is to [ __ ]
a stranger's wife we actually have a
didgeridoo in the sound vault though
there's a vibrator that's like I told
you to leave that at home no matter
James using an electric shaver up in the
sound booth I'm not sure alright let's
get to some emails shall we James hit it
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reactions yes this
email is maybe my favorite in a long
long time Ralph and keV been listening
since day one just got my friend Derek
hooked on the show and I just received
an interesting phone call from him and I
thought I'd share the story he's just
now getting caught up with the show and
was intrigued by the Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
tumblr site
he logged onto the site for those who
don't know that's a a site that features
all the jokes about how big Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is he locked on to the
site had some laughs and then left to go
watch his little brothers baseball game
while in the stands his dad texted him
with a picture message it was of his
laptop which he had left open with the
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] page on it below it a
single message is there something we
should know about it read I'm pretty
sure Derek could have had hardcore porn
a KKK website hell even a cop-out
fanpage and not been questioned but not
apparently Ln C's page I just wanted to
thank you for outing my buddy to his
parents well it's our pleasure Eric
we're happy to do it
this next email starts it's from Matt
listening to your podcast over in
Australia and loving it my best and
oldest friend wig Oh put me onto the
podcast and I am grateful to him I
wondered if Ralph could pass on a
message to wig Oh for me as Charlton
Heston I've been keeping this a secret
from him for 10 years but now it's time
for the truth to come out so wait he's
he's written a secret he wants you to
read as Charlton Heston you
why do people keep using us go ahead
first em I think we made this may be a
new service we can offer no we could
charge for this if you have a deep dark
secret you want to reveal to someone you
love send it in and I'll do it in a
character yeah maybe it makes it easier
if you hear it like a wacky voice yeah
yeah like a war was gonna tell you a
cancer there's something in sighs you
and not a penis this time do you tell me
that it's Dudley Moore I'm ready man I'm
ready to a greater gasps through all
those acceptance stages ago right to
accept this work for Hobson yeah yeah he
went in that movie yeah the first one
not the second no not that one anyway so
this is the deep dark secret - we go
from Charlton Heston we go from that we
go ten years ago when we lived together
you were trying to nail a hot chick
named Linda but never got anywhere well
one day you went to work and I hopped
into bed with her and fooled around it
ended with me giving her a pearl
necklace
and I made this that's sort of easy
sorry we go this comes from Marcus
Newton from Sweden Ralf and Kevin I did
artwork for you in between listening to
you guys and [ __ ] all the hot blondes
here in Sweden by the way Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big I made a frame of it he
did artwork for us I'm going to throw it
up on the screen here this is you and me
on Hollywood babble-on
it's made entirely of beads that's
adorable yeah look at look at the frame
it's a giant blue vein [ __ ] rolling all
the way around yeah yeah ads I hope
you'll like it because portraying Kevin
giving the microphone fellatio with
beads was a [ __ ]
he writes let's zoom in there on Kevin's
picture we came to see him deep
throating the microphone it's all him it
was like a copy of that for my
daughter's room and so you shall this is
dad you Marcus Newton Ralph again my
name is Raul I live up in Seattle I'm a
huge fan just just what happened I
thought I heard something
another drink yeah we're ally man put
that down dude what is it mother mother
Yes Mother
I'm just doing jokes just wanted to make
a suggestion for a new quick segment on
HBO the idea is to take five minutes or
so and recommend an older obscure movie
talk about the actors when it was made
in the overall plot the reason I asked
this is because all the movies you and
camp mention and recommend especially
during Tinseltown stiffs are really good
but you only mention them quickly it'll
be awesome if you could delve a little
deeper into a movie that you think is
good that's from Raul mmm that's a good
idea we should do that I think Ralph and
I are gonna start another podcast we
won't do it in front of the audience
we'll just do it at home I'm gonna sit
around watch boo talk about movies that
we like play clips and [ __ ] like that
yes Ralph was on sir I do a morning
radio show it SModcast calm
and ralph was on and one morning the
morning he was on we sat around just
talking not doing a show like this and
it was fun people like oh my god you
guys are real people ya know because
they just assumed that we just sit
around all the time and be like Justin
Bieber right what an [ __ ] you know no
you know so I think doing a podcast of
us talking about movies and [ __ ] we like
just as ourselves would be kind of fun
yeah it'd be boring from the live
audience yeah yeah yeah we do it in your
house your in your robe and slippers
yeah stoned yeah I could show up drunk
playful yeah
glass of wine yeah maybe a dick falls in
the hands now is it's not gay in the
morning I've heard that up until noon
you're good tell my wife that all the
time yeah come back with a [ __ ] all over
my face not in the morning alright this
emails from Craig Gus this is impressive
he said Ralph and Kevin had a good laugh
last week at your impressions of arnold
schwarzenegger and rachel t cotton from
Total Recall we last week we did the bit
where they're stuck on the surface of
Mars with no oxygen and they're
struggling in their eyes are bulging out
if you may remember it's a bit they went
on too long maybe so I decided to write
and direct a film based on you guys
together on Mars you guys are hilarious
keep up the good work babble the [ __ ] on
from Craig this is his film I want to
show it to you it's not too long I it's
a little more serious than we usually do
here in the show but I was so impressed
by the work you put into it I thought
we'd show it's called Babel recall and
it's available on youtube if you want to
check it out if you're listening at home
but here is that here's the entire film
of Babel recall
there you go that's babble recall right
all your hard work and making my
favorite email of the week we're reading
the credits yeah is a great my favorite
email the week comes from Nick [ __ ]
it starts I'm really sorry I meant to
click download HBO nut email HBO but I
am as high as [ __ ] sincerely Nick short
but sweet I like his commitment he
licked it he was in he felt he had to
write some yeah it was just like I'm
here already that's right it's not yeah
if you're there already that's right
every week we say goodbye to some people
in show business that we admire
it's a sad segment but one we like to do
because it gives people a chance to
closure closure and the chance of the
audience Mabel to hear about some folks
they didn't know their work previously
it's a second movie called Tinseltown
steps and now another edition of
[Music]
they will be missed a lot of emails
about this actress this week from the UK
especially she was a British actress
named Anna Massey she was the daughter
of Raymond Massey does that name ring a
bell to you he was in the day yeah I
think he was in Arsenic and Old Lace and
a couple other big movies in the 40s and
50s okay she died at the age of 73 this
week she's mostly known for starring in
two big big movies she was in
Hitchcock's movie frenzy mm-hmm where
she played a lead in that and she was
also in a film called peeping tom by
Michael Powell you ever see that for
peeping tom it's it's classic it's
really it's a noise a lot sexier than I
was who was in it no one you've heard of
Anna she was the lead and Karl böhm I
think was the male lead in it but here's
the basic premise it was kind of like
psycho right whereas this guy this
German guy so you know he's bad well
they did invent world war two as true he
is the son of a psychologist and a
psychologist was a little [ __ ] up so
he would take films of his young son in
very fearful situations he'd wake him up
and they'll night throw a lizard on him
and then film him so he could capture
fear in the face of a young person and
he would film him through his entire
childhood he filmed him they made a
movie about this yeah cuz this happened
to me every night of my life and I was
wondering who my father did with all
that food is this guy grows up and he's
little off yes so what he has to do in
order to get off is to lure young models
into his art studio his photo studio
right and he murders them on film and
that's how he gets off you like this
movie I love this movie
it's like psycho right now Anna played
the young girl who falls in love with
this guy unbeknownst to her he's crazy
and it's a great performance it's a
great film it's a great film about
voyeurism and about film in general at
the time was considered perverse and
sort of evil but it's been in time it's
it's been accepted as a classic I
brought a little taste of the film for
you this is the scene where she first
meets this guy for some reason she
thinks he's charming even though once
again I mentioned he's German it's very
scary here's a scene from peeping tom
when I came in were you looking at some
films yes of yours yes I'd like to see
them why no I'm being rude but I really
would like to see them it would be a
birthday present from you to me I'm
going to fondle the milk now that's how
it was bad he's fondling milk yeah so
she worked for about 50 years after that
film it worked the whole time won a
BAFTA and everything she died at the age
of 73 this week big bucket a big bucket
of win every once in a while we also
like to talk about celebrities who do
something cool doesn't happen very often
we would like to highlight it when it
does it's a segment we call Hollywood
helpers
[Music]
thanks mister thanks mister
you may have heard about this this week
you too was in concert in Nashville and
we make fun of Bono here on the show we
do who we I don't ever remember remember
engaging at bottom I don't know I don't
remember what I was gonna say Wow medic
Smith has had a stroke oh my god you all
right I powered through it though I
don't ever remember talking about Bono
we put up on all the time how it's
really hard to sing rock and roll up
here when so many people are dying so
I'm gonna pass out some razor blades in
the audience and like y'all to cut
yourselves because people in Africa are
starving so when I sing with or without
you know that I'm really talking about
famine and AIDS yeah but he's a very
cool dude
okay turns out this week he was
performing in Nashville they're doing
the show the 360 world tour they've been
on tour for like eight years now with
this tour yeah it's never ending and
usually they end the show with a moment
of surrender that's their last song for
the night they walk off the stage well
does it go but I don't know I don't know
not a huge YouTube fans but that's why
you're always making fun with a guy
that's free in Nashville they're about
to walk off the stage and Bono looks
down in the front row and he sees a sign
and it's held up by a blind fan legally
blind duty as a sign up said I'd like to
play a song for my wife and so Bono
looks down and brings the dude up on
stage he helps him up on stage it gives
him an acoustic guitar and says what do
you want to play and he says I want to
dedicate a song to my wife I love her
and I'd like to play a song for her and
the song they chooses to play is all I
want is you and if you've seen this on
youtube I mean I can't barely tell the
story without person you're gonna make
me cry it's a very cool thing that Bono
did I brought a little piece of tape you
can find it on YouTube but he brings him
up on stage he gives him a guitar and
lets him start to play and then he joins
in and by the end you won't see it here
but the whole band joins in and and the
place goes nuts but here's a little
taste of Bono being a Hollywood help her
what's your wife's name
entering my wife's name is Andrea
dedicated there they just
[Music]
you say
[Applause]
you want diamond on a ring of gold you
say you want
story to remain until all the promises
we may from the cradle when I is here
[Music]
many back on stage joined in they played
the full song with this guy playing
guitar bono gave him the guitar at the
end of the night helped him back into
the audience with his wife pretty
[ __ ] cool
although bono did push him off the edge
of the stage he was blind and he thought
it'd be funny to see him plummet to the
mosh pit you know I was gonna do it now
you know the African feel like making a
point a political point yeah this next
segment is just blown up I don't know
how it started we started playing video
clips you may have been away when we
started this bit but we start playing
video clips of bloopers from movies that
were left in the movies I think it
started with the kid from Back to the
Future 3 pointing to his penis yes in
the background behind Doc Brown he was
grabbing his junk yes and then we did a
scene from Jedi where Harrison Ford
grabs Carrie Fisher's boob while the
while the stormtroopers are attacking we
played the Harry Potter map it shows the
two kids humping on the the marauders
map yes
Teen Wolf we showed that scene we're
hoses Kaka missiles [ __ ] out
yeah by the way since I got a lot of
emails over the week it turns out that's
actually a woman in that scene pulling
her [ __ ] and we don't know what she's
pulling out but it she needs to see a
doctor immediately no idea my mom was
acting
[Music]
so this segments become so popular kevin
has dubbed it [ __ ] that should not be do
you even spent any time thinking about
these titles no that one just came to me
and someone was kind enough his name is
the Brandon Marsh shot he was kind
enough to send him a new jingle for this
segment James everything sounds better
in harmony that auto-tuning [ __ ]
either that was pretty that was real
this week [ __ ] that should not be comes
from a classic Raiders of the Lost Ark
one of my favorite films that was back
when Harrison Ford could still speak one
more time Harrison Ford for the crowd
mmm we made number four George said
crystal skulls but in Raiders he could
still talk and this scene is when
Indiana Jones is threatening to blow up
the ark with a bazooka yeah he says
unless they free Marion yeah Ravens okay
if no one else would Marion Ravenwood
and Bela
be able enough to peace Freeman quasi
French is so good in this yeah he is
talking Indiana Jones and I never
noticed this before and I've seen this
movie a billion times and apparently in
this scene if you look carefully we'll
play it a couple times a fly lands on
his face I remember this crawls into his
mouth dude just keeps going stays in
character doesn't blink doesn't bat an
eye doesn't say hey Steve can we cut
that I'm eating bugs here nothing stays
committed god bless them so I brought it
for you to see Paul Freeman has been
Locke eating a bug in Raiders of the
Lost Ark will played a couple times for
your
enjoyment your persistence surprises
even me and they're given a good Merson
me there's your [ __ ] that should not be
for this week that one was dangerous
because I just wanted to keep watching
the movie because I'm like I know what
happens next
yeah I wonder if they if the flies face
also melts off when they take the lid
off and then look at the arc as well as
Belloc's all right take a look at some
hi HBO headlines we start with new
releases this weekend some new films in
theaters this week and some big ones
some star Kevin James and talking
gorillas how dare you how can you not
love [ __ ] talking gorillas he puts
him in a t-shirt takes him to Friday's
people did you see it [ __ ] no will will
get to my hatred for that movie in a
moment but I want to start with the
movie I was actually looking forward to
saying I'd heard about this a couple
months ago I'm a sucker for and look I'm
not a big animal lover I like animals
look at me wrong I'm not a hunter or
anything I got a dog I like my dog but
I'm not a huge animal fan but I am loved
I do love when people try to communicate
with monkeys you know that Coco the
talking [ __ ] gorilla they talk sign
language too I want to marry that [ __ ]
I would be very happy living a long long
life with Coco or [ __ ] Jefferson
Kongo Amy Amy said yeah yeah like that
[ __ ] gorilla could tell you she'll
Amy sad Amy hungry Amy good time Amy
jerk you are Amy
ami roll over and give you one she gave
me [ __ ] won't tell your wife it's not
gay if it's with Amy you know but I'm
talking about real real [ __ ] in real
life and real life I like project Dex
Matthew Broderick now people talking -
chips for real I don't want any Planet
of the Apes [ __ ] where Caesar of a
sudden rises up and gets armed I want to
say yeah I'm with the nice regular
monkeys that we try to talk to okay and
I'd heard about this monkey before
called NIM in the 70s there was a
project NIM where they tried to get this
chimpanzee it was an orphan - chimpanzee
they tried to make it as human as
possible
by raising it amongst a human family
heard this now there's a documentary
that comes out this weekend in limited
release you can check it out called
Project NIM
I actually don't do this my brought a
little taste of the trailer because I
was so fascinated by the storyline I'm
so excited about the film here is an
actual scene from the trailer of Project
NIM from from the 70s this project they
put this monkey this chimp with a human
family and the woman who was raising the
monkey maybe took it a little bit too
far but you can tell for yourself
everything was about treating him like a
human being
he liked alcohol he loves driving fast
and cars
persuade him for a couple of months it
seemed completely natural I couldn't
believe it
she breastfed the monkey for a couple of
months she says in that clip
there's NIMH now yeah she bread my god
the chimp while she was raising him you
become if anyone finds out you become
that crazy lady who lets chimp suck her
tits yes like it's a long nickname but
you'll learn it I like the one at the
end it says it was the 70s but all kinds
of monkeys were sucking on tits in the
70s it really was very very common
occurence really so that's alton
theaters this weekend also this weekend
his movie called Horrible Bosses
starring Jason Bateman Charlie Day Jason
Sudeikis looks very funny Jennifer
Anderson also stars in this film
okay shows off a little bit of her cans
that's gotta be good a little bit of her
one her boobs
her breasts Oh was about a monkey sucker
no more anything show them off I say get
me in the theater just a poster with
hugging that chick with a [ __ ] chimp
just like eyes half rolled back in
ecstasy and [ __ ] it's a little
controversial we just lost them thank
you so much
I'm not saying I'd make the movie I'm
saying that's what would get me in the
theater cuz I'd see that poster and be
like holy [ __ ] she must not be doing
well makes you wonder about Marcel on
friends but she was always going on
there backstage zookeeper also opens up
this weekend with Kevin James who plays
a zookeeper who talks to the [ __ ] no
no one wants to see this here's the
thing when since you were older than the
age of eight let's say women's last time
you're entertained by animals [ __ ]
talking to people
Eddie Murphy dr. Doolittle [ __ ]
really yes those movies were [ __ ]
okay yeah there was a moment somebody
yeah Roger Rabbit somebody said that's
cartoons but I don't want to see CGI'd
lips on a lemur you know I just I'm not
interested it's not funny and so that's
what this movie has with this movie he
turns to the animals for the animals
talk to him and they tell them how to
meet chicks I know it's worse than a
monkey sucking on at it I think it's
more perverse Kevin James haunts me man
cuz people are always just like Kevin
James my point of being say that and I'm
always looking behind me yeah but they
mean me and I don't want to [ __ ] be
like no I'm the other fat Kevin breast
the less successful one you know so I
just go with it where I'm like Leah
Remini says hi it's not even close
really no no we just have the first name
that's it and you're funny
which is how I tell you two apart no no
this dude he's doing well everyone likes
him he's in a lot of movies make money
is in that mall cobbler I made mall rats
made two million he made paul blart mall
cop 200 million so your one word off yes
I just got a little closer son of a
[ __ ] a few more ball shots that would
have been American congratulations at
Natalie Portman she's got a newborn son
with her fiance Benjamin Neil up again
lemme guess they're twins named Luke and
Leia no this is the real world it's just
one baby it's a boy and for the longest
time she held back the name she did not
want to release the name of the child
but she has finally told everyone the
name his name is Aleph I left ala Aleph
al e pH Aleph I love it this weapon
analysis
are the anti-semitic bastards do you
love it enough it Alif it turns out is
the first letter of the Hebrew alphabet
okay that's where I live comes from
right on and so I guess you having more
children because she's named the first
one one or a so she can keep trying good
way to keep track of how many letters
you think in that Jewish out of the 26
I'm a guessing yes all right I'm looking
forward to seeing her have many
twenty-five points right on man
I loved Aleph when I was growing up
especially remember him he used to eat
cats who's from the planet melmac yeah
yeah yeah Willy no sweat my pet is the
other guy Gavin you must be worried
breaking news just today turns out the
situation has left jersey shore please
please can we get some suicide Watchers
up on the balcony for uh for this news
it was bad enough when Vinny left Vinny
left July 1st he walked out which ones
Vinny Vinny's the Italian one with the
tan right who does the laundry
alright yeah the situation now has also
walked out I don't know what MTV's gonna
do but they're down there filming fifth
season Jersey Shore right now and two of
their main cast members have walked out
of that house are they shooting in Italy
they shot in Italy and they went right
from Italy went to Seaside Heights New
Jersey they're filming the next season
already and apparently there's big
troubles in the Jersey Shore house oh
Lord
well it is the Jersey Shore you can
expect them to tumble out the screen
door and fight on the lawn at any moment
yes I think we should send in the SEAL
Team six or whatever we sent in to take
care of bin Laden then just DoubleTap
the whole cast and be done with it let's
start fresh
let's start fresh you always go so
drastic I'd begin with let's just fire
them they're like let's just fire it I
didn't get finally the chance they can
come back yeah if you dump their bodies
in the ocean off of a frigate you'll
know you know what you you don't be
bothered with The Situation's abs again
there you go there's the double tap
thank you so much Jim ten short lunch
Daniel Radcliff came out this week and
said he is gay no no let damn it let the
man finish oh good
Daniel Radcliffe came out this week he's
gay gonna have to rewrite this whole
joke in the British edition of GQ
magazine Daniel Radcliffe revealed his
game Daniel Radcliffe gave up drinking
this week he was drunk the 21 year old
says he became too reliant on alcohol to
function he said he gave up drinking
when he realized he was partying too
much during the filming of the last few
Harry Potter movies [ __ ] up against
that would be the best place to get
[ __ ] up I would get really drunk and
cruise through diagonally and [ __ ] like
that forget it they said as much as I
would love to be the person that goes to
parties and has a couple of drinks and
has a nice time that doesn't work for me
so now he is clean and sober I would
have [ __ ] quitter die I never saw him
as the party boy never saw pictures of
him he said I saw him and he's like oh
man if there was ever a camera around
but I've never seen him remotely tied to
anything somewhat scandalous and his
drunken behavior so he if he was truly
drinking he hit at will he knew there
was a problem when he woke up next to
Hagrid one morning that's it isn't
that's when you know you're [ __ ] up
and I've woken up next to a few Hagrid's
myself it's like I can appreciate it but
at 21 you got to give up drinking yeah
that sucked me these two 20 rolls of can
treat their miserable over here they're
cursing Daniel I know no look you're
giving up what we would only [ __ ]
lost the booze dad you know Paris
Hilton's got problems confirmation from
upstairs people are glad she's got a
stalker named James Rainford apparently
James is wherever she is over the long
holiday weekend he was outside of her
beach home peering through the windows
shirtless now there is a yeah it sounds
a good time to me pressing my nipples
against Paris's window there's a
restraining order against this gentleman
he can't get closer than 200 feet
apparently to Paris he violated that so
the cops showed up and pulled him pulled
him away but she's been scared to death
of this guy for some time he apparently
he's quite the stalker I would never do
that
stalk Paris Hilton no take my shirt oh
oh okay
so Paris has upped her security it says
today she has hired four armed guards to
patrol her beachfront property as a new
security system that features multiple
cameras and motion detectors and I'd say
Paris I would be so quick to shoo away
your fans if I reel that he might be the
last one you might want to stick around
it's weird it sounds like she lives in
the third act of lethal weapon 2 now yes
a house with dudes surrounding it with
guns and [ __ ] we got to find a way to
drag those pylons watch that kind of
crashing down dina Lohan inexplicably in
news this week she is telling anyone who
will listen that she wants to be on
Dancing with the Stars apparently she
was at Lindsay's 25th birthday party
saying she's already contacted the
producers asking to be on the show and
they were like you're not a star just
Dancing with the Stars not Dancing with
your mom the stars moms that's on CBS
next season the older Channel Charlie
Sheen is in the news oh stop it I hope
those are ironic cheers winning
he's gonna be roasted on Comedy Central
oh well that's finally someone's gonna
make jokes about Charlie Sheen it's
about goddamn time outside of the Mark
Twain award I think this is the highest
honor we bestow our artists in this
country the Comedy Central Roast
it'll be on September the 19th which
just happens to be the same night that
the new two and a Half Men starring
Ashton Kutcher is gonna be on geez Oh
which one do I why or do I just plunge a
knitting needle into my eyes I'll take
number three I'm by winning I win here
no in there not one Charlie by the way
is working on a new sitcom I never heard
this Joe Rock yes or something like that
well there's no network yet but
apparently it is based on the 2003 movie
anger management remember that without
it yeah with Jack Nicholson so he's
doing a the jack role he will play an
anger management counselor who deals
with people who have anger management
while he's trying to deal with his own
issues right um here's the thing there's
no script yet and Charlie has said he
needs to work side by side with whoever
writes the pilot which means it will
never be written because no one is
desperate enough to sit in the room with
Charlie Sheen and write a script yeah
Kevin what is so both of those gonna be
on the same night yeah so the first
episode of the generally rebooted Two
and a Half Men I mean the same night as
The Comedy Central Roast of Charlie
Sheen what do you want to do I want to
have dr. Conrad Murray give me some
propofol
take the long dirt nap because it's time
to check out fair enough yeah and you
may be getting out of the movie business
just at the right time Kevin why I read
this news today they are making Angry
Birds the movie variety reports and gree
birds you know that [ __ ] game you
play on your iPhone that's gonna be a
movie but to be fair dude Angry Birds
has more of a story than transformers
three point well-taken
every time you clear a board they let
you know what's happening that's trill
can pigs they won again and they you
know let's just fraught with sequels the
whole thing is like the pigs keep
winning at least you know to root for
yeah exactly
well you know you're not far off from
what the producer of the film actually
said about this which is my head
exploded because I can't believe
sometimes these people buy their own
[ __ ] but it's pretty magical let me
read you what the David Maisel says he's
the producer of the film there has been
so much chatter about an Angry Birds
movie and now it's real
David may be confusing chatter with
mockery the process is starting now he
says people are interacting with these
characters six inches from them each
time they play and that creates an
emotional connection this is not an
American thing it's not even a finished
thing are the Angry Birds from Finland I
was a weird pick but this dude's Sooey I
want to finish all over his chest he's
not making much sense it's a global
thing that's something I've never seen
before it will be exciting to expand
this intellectual property within
Hollywood that if you're talking like
that you're not making art man and if
you're making a game a movie about that
video game you're not making art you're
just making a crass commercial but
here's my question
do you ever enjoy watching anybody play
video games no like we all play Angry
Birds and then we'd go to the theater
for like in 90 minutes we'd be like
trying to direct them from our seats
like who wants to why I don't want to
watch people play Angry Birds and
sitting in a movie watching an Angry
Birds movie is equivalent to watching
people play Angry Birds I say no I think
we drop by this house with some
slingshots and some eggs and we enact
the movie for him live in front of his
house we just helped him just as long as
we bring the triangle birth that goes
through oh that's a good one cuz that'll
pump through the walls right and then
bring the exploding bird that like you
get two hits have it break something
then don't bring that stupid [ __ ] red
bird that does nothing useless that dude
is the [ __ ] Kevin Smith of Angry
Birds just a lazy [ __ ] nothing good
comes from a no man he's got clerks
that's it at it in transformers you were
just talking about that dude ghost works
too while we're talking about
transformers earlier rosie
huntington-whiteley mm-hmm the new
Megan Fox he's the new Megan Fox such a
wild damn ooh what's in the name since
this is amantha anyone keep going
she was asked what's it like to be a
movie star I would like to be in
transformer she's looking forward making
the next one she said no what's really
she led with no here's what she said
about the experience you're in the Sun
all day long dirty and smelly was like
boot camp
oh [ __ ] you Jesus Christ meanwhile
friends are saying they're concerned
about Rosie because she is partying
harder than ever she shows up for
photoshoots as a model looking like she
hasn't slept in days smells of booze and
cigarettes so she can stink for a party
but she can't stink for michaelbay
that's what she said well meanwhile
they're saying that jason statham her
boyfriend may take over for Shia LaBeouf
in transformers 4 they would might do it
together
really they're a hot item now and she
wants to do in the next film and they
might they're looking for a new male
lead
what was that [ __ ] movie nice to
drive in the car the messenger the
transporting the train combine those two
movies the transporter verse more than
meets the eye we gotta go bumblebee I
have been a guy to a chick in the trunk
so that's gone let's transform into
something where you say and then the
[ __ ] bumblebee is like okay and he
turns into robot crushers Jason Statham
inside of himself blood pours out credit
credit
I like him though I wouldn't mind seeing
him in that that's great yeah punch the
[ __ ] out of a robot man ah that's
nothing a lot of work it really does how
about yell out watch it I'll do that
Kevin directed it be like Jason Statham
in an obtainer sitting across from a
robot having a conversation about Star
Wars son so let me ask you bumblebee do
you think Chewbacca ever had to get a
haircut because it seems like to me that
if it's hairs like normal hair it would
just keep growing and growing but you
never see Chewbacca get a haircut never
thought of that
yeah because c-3po is a protocol droid
so when you won't look any product came
a trim has
credits that was really [ __ ] hurtful
man is that how you see my work no and
not at all
you're out of your mind dude if I was
making that movie there wouldn't even be
a robot they'd just be talking about the
robot two dudes sitting there gone isn't
it [ __ ] up that just one block away
pluses are turning into robots and
beating each other up yeah it's like not
as [ __ ] up as this [ __ ] I got the
other night and then they talked about
that and then [ __ ] Yoda a joke made
in them credit right [ __ ] I'm trying to
know what I was thinking a little
respect
Emma stones on the cover of Elle
magazine your abs are [ __ ] lutely
right people Emma Stone is Ralph's a
celebrity some would say crush I say
stalk how dare you sir you're a little
too into the surf I just ate a
respectful distance from miss stone the
entire time as far as she knows 200 feet
that's right the legal limit I mean
uh-huh
I mean I'm at him right there at the 200
foot limit totally did an interview this
week where she said although she is
straight and dating Andrew Garfield
she's dating spider-man yeah British
[ __ ] spider-man spider-man says all the
chicks he can man Emma Stone and
spider-man yes stop it stop rubbing it
in she's got that web all over he's like
whipped with stop
that's like Oh Peter saved me with your
web page me in the great no man that's
the spider-man movie we need to see no
villain not needed just sympho can his
lady for two hours Emma says although
she straight she is in touch with her
girl-on-girl side and when asked if she
had a female crush she admitted
Christina Hendricks from Mad Men ok can
we throw the girls up together on the
screen just for a minute oh sweet Jesus
that has a lot of redhead right there
and my friends not for you not for me
now a lot of no head for you up there
Emma says it's a no brainer
everything about her does it for me
that's my kind of woman she says in
conjunction with that news like a little
something to announce as you may know
Kevin and I are gonna be down at the San
Diego Comic Con next weekend is it no
two weeks two weeks from now and I I've
been asked to host a couple of panels
have been asked to hope the Dexter panel
this year yes I have previously and the
Batman 45th anniversary TV series huge
shoes well this week they asked me to
host the amazing spider-man panel with
Miss Emma Stone
I am the only one element away from a
three-way with me Christina Hendricks
and Emma Stone
what's the element Christina Hendricks
yes the good news is that Andrew
Garfield is gonna be there as well so
you have the elements for a three-way
now I don't
scrawny Brit garmi hates oh look there's
Pippa maybe like what what what boom I'm
doing his girlfriend wait your sex leave
in a hurry really ride the horse there
man [ __ ] bra got that right Taylor you
were like a [ __ ] five-year-old
outside the supermarket just that's just
perverse madam west in a threeway this
guy said like I haven't been there done
that me annamund Burt right to the
bat-poles
holy cornhole Johnny Depp according to
LA Times as in talks to do Pirates of
he's not here it's just a story I'm just
reading his name they just celebrate the
thought of his colleague did you say
death they like death he must have a
dick you're doing a lot of this tonight
a lot of face touchin I'm actin a little
bit zooming Johnny Depp is in toxic or
in the LA Times to do Pirates of the
Caribbean five foot a shock because the
last one did so poorly right yeah yeah
turns out now we know why in the same
article they mentioned that pirates so
far has made for Johnny Depp's personal
fortune 350 million dollars
yeah in case you didn't hear that number
350 million dollars to him just him yeah
where's the womb now yeah that's the I
will say this though man like he this is
a dude who for years before he made 350
million dollars always kind of put in an
original performance you never saw that
dude do anything less than like shoot
the moon right though finally like in
this movie now we're odds de rigueur
that he does the who's he doing Keith
Richards yeah and we all kind of know it
but when they were first shoot in that
movie he had to put his [ __ ] balls on
the line to play that character because
the studio was like we saw the dailies
man like are you doing Keith Richards
and he was like yeah it's a choice and
they were like choose again but he stuck
to his guns he's like no he kept asking
is he doing gay gay lawyer it's not
gauge girls and they put a stone sappy
but he did he put it out there he stood
up for that performance and that defined
it like this was a movie a lot of people
don't remember the first movie when they
were making it people were like whoa oh
it's [ __ ] I was doing prediction it
was a total Hollywood doom prediction
they lost their sets in a flood and or
fire maybe both like they had a lot of
setbacks and then people were saying
like he's doing this weird accent and
that weird accent got him three hundred
fifty million dollars so the moral of
that story is like sometimes you got to
stick with the gut instinct he did and
god bless him he's got [ __ ] almost
half a billion dollars for a good idea
and the wonderful American thing about
it all is all you had to do was pretend
to be someone else you know it's like
you didn't like created from scratch
he's just like I'll be that guy
it's the brilliance of simplicity while
we're talking about how much money
people make Forbes magazine released the
list this week of the highest-paid
actresses in Hollywood at the top at
number one was a tie between Angelina
Jolie and Sarah Jessica Parker not angry
30 million dollars they each made last
year alone 30 million dollars Angelina
Jolie from salt and the tourists Sarah
Jessica Parker for winning the Preakness
why do you say that what does that mean
I don't understand you think she looks
kind of a horsey could be $31 she made
from Sex in the City the movie SEC City
- I guess it was and the TV series and
her perfume Ottawa she was [ __ ] me
because I would have all that money -
like you'd be coming and you'd have
access to 30 million dollars right now I
could come and that's it yeah this chick
comes with a bank account as well so
after you were done nodding you'd be
like oh let's eat off diamonds
can I get the money without [ __ ] her
can I do that is there not an option
no can i [ __ ] matthew broderick instead
it's preferable I'd rather do Ferris
Bueller than Carrie Bradshaw Ferris
Bueller gets off all over your face who
else gets paid wait wait that can't be
the only two people get paid no they
have a whole list of people here a few
more out
yeah what's Kevin Smith about actress
list they were the top two they were
tied at number one okay
then Jennifer Aniston at number two tied
with Reese Witherspoon they each weren't
earned twenty eight million dollars last
year Wow
alone Wow Julia Roberts Kristen Stewart
they were tied at 20 million dollars
each okay Katherine Heigl made 19
million dollars using this these shows
is like casting calls cuz I listen to
the audience react here right there
write them down well know like boo I'm
like stay the [ __ ] away not like any of
these chicks would ever think about
doing a [ __ ] Ken Smith joint anyway
you know put Katherine Heigl and hit
somebody a lot of people have asked me
to but now they just want you to hit
Katherine very camera D has made 18
million dollars last year Sandra Bullock
made fifteen million dollars and Meryl
Streep that hack she made ten million
dollars Wow alright I'm not jealous of
them at all no we don't need money
anyway money's for suckers you know we
have love speaking of Sex in the City
bridesmaids just surpassed Sex in the
City to becoming the highest-grossing
r-rated female comedy of all time
as of this week it made over 153 million
dollars in America alone so
congratulations to those guys by the way
sexist City however still holds the
record of the highest grossing r-rated
comedy starring a horse because
Secretariat was a drama secretary with a
drama Bret Michaels lead man of poison
and guy who seems always to be dying to
me I'm not sure what's going on with
Bret but he always seems to be right on
the edge of death he was the gentleman
had some sort of like a hole in his
heart and your ISM or something he had a
hole in his head he had a broken nose he
wears a [ __ ] bandanna all the time I
don't know what that's all about holding
them together his head together yeah he
is suing the Tony Awards aren't we all I
watched this year I'm suing and CBS
because he claims in 2009 he was on the
Tony Awards they were doing a salute to
Rock of Ages the Broadway musical
features all the 80s hits and he was on
there onstage with poison and he stayed
out a little bit too long milking the
applause for his lip-syncing and he
turned around to walk up stage and he
clotheslined himself into a piece of
scenery which is the funniest [ __ ]
thing you'll ever see in the Tony or
he's like yeah so cool bang just smashes
into this piece of scenery broke his
nose and he claims it gave him the brain
aneurysm that almost killed him so he's
suing this week they just announced that
it's moving from Los Angeles to New York
because that's where the accident
happened
federal judge says that's where the
lawsuit should take place he's also
suing CBS because he says they chose to
air him slamming into the scenery
instead of hitting the seven second
delay and skipping over it and he was
embarrassed and he said on YouTube that
shot got 27 million views
and I think personally it is it is sad
no it's really not right to make fun of
someone's misfortune I think in a video
that's how I personally feel but I know
Kevin feels differently so I would like
to show you if you know if you have a
moment
Bret Michaels slamming into a piece of
scenery as it comes down just
clotheslines themselves I'm gonna show
you the clip first how it aired and then
we'll take a break and then I'll zoom in
for you and then we'll just show it over
and over and over again because
seriously I practically pissed myself
laughing every time I see this here is
that Bret Michaels lip-synching on the
Tony Awards
[Music]
the crowd turns around man
[Music]
[Applause]
and
I can watch that all day it didn't
happen that many times that night though
no I did not know I just kind of I have
a loop running in my house that's where
I pulled that from it's just when you
come to my house that's just constantly
on the TV's the board you said BAM the
funnier cat Katy Perry in the news and I
love Katy Perry yeah after her Ryder
which had 42 pages of explicit
directions and I had to treat Keri Katy
Perry when she was on tour she was in
the news this week because it turns out
that she regularly flies her cats to
visit with her when she's on tour
California girls are really spoiled yeah
puts her cats on a plane flies them to
the city that she's in on tour so she
can visit with them puts them back on a
plane and sends them home and they threw
you off a plane yeah no what the [ __ ]
man she sounds lonely
she sounds like a cat lady like Susan
Boyle would do that
I need my special friends spoiled
musicians Prince also in the news this
week this he takes the cake this is
spectacular he was performing at an
event called the hop farm Music Festival
it sounds like a petting zoo around the
Easter for the kids doesn't it the hop
farm Music Festival he was 80 feet away
from the stage in his dressing room he
demanded in his contract that a stretch
limo stop by and pick him up and drive
him the 80 feet to the stage he got it
no they did it yep nobody takes a stand
it just goes come on dude no come on
dance he is a strange duck he had his
dressing room rebuilt three times by the
way at the same event they had to tear
down a rebuilt it three times to his
specifications and it needed everything
in miniature and it looked like like a
dollhouse
there's a little Barbie sitting at the
dinner table he's he's of an odd dude
man when I shot a documentary with him
once there I read it on that DVD and
whatnot but he they refer to where he
lives in his world as prints world and
his producer was explaining I was like
what's prints world and she's like well
prints world is like prints will call
you up and be like it's two o'clock in
the morning in Minnesota
I need a camel in February and you go
like okay let me break that down part by
part and tell you how that's just not
feasible and he can't hear that if you
go like how are we supposed to do that
he's like what are you talking about oh
and hangs up because he's just like you
would figure it out like of course you
could get me a camel the two o'clock in
the morning in February in Minnesota
like don't they have them growing on
trees around here she says that's kind
of prints world that dude just wore you
know he's used to getting it sounds like
the worst theme park ever prints world
TV news
David Hasselhoff has land land an actual
acting role this week he's going to be
on sons of anarchy good for him man do
you make sure you watch tons of it I do
I do want Stan's event okay that's why
I'm surprised they were hiring David
Hasselhoff yeah it's an actual show with
real acting and stuff yeah what's he
gonna do on there I trust Kurt Sutter
I'm sure he knows what he's done he's
gonna play Dondo is the name of his
character a former porn star who is now
a girl-on-girl porn film director
why do you think they specified
girl-on-girl because that's the hottest
kind this is so weird man like if they'd
left that out would you've just have
assumed oh he's a gay porn director
Hasselhoff I guess this is kind of a
resurgence for Dave into the real acting
world he did a run on Young and the
Restless sort of as a farewell for that
TV series that's going off the air the
soap opera he's also in piranhas three
double D the sequel to piranha 3d and
folks say people close to and say he's
actually trying to get back to some
serious acting again he wants to
establish himself as a real actor and
the reason you can tell that is because
he also this week released the Hoffs
tickle the hopsicle as you can imagine
is a popsicle that looks just like David
Hasselhoff that you suck on yeah it was
released this week unfortunately it's
only in the UK but I got a picture of
David posing with the hopsicle this is
David and the hopsicle I should you not
it's real and it's raspberry so he
thinks you're curious so you know he's a
serious actor again when he has a
confection named after him apparently
there's a video on YouTube I haven't
seen yet but he goes around asking women
in the streets of London to lick his
lolli which is what the the word is the
British term is for popsicle lick my
lolli my lolli I would just go to chicks
and be like put me in your mouth all
right stop the bed sound hotter and more
desperate yes the both and the like how
dare you I'm like no it's my [ __ ] keV
cycle
put me in your mouth more TV news oh
there's trouble at the Chelsea Handler
sitcom oh I will I always have to be the
lone Chelsea a voice in this room yeah I
saw a preview for the show I liked it oh
[ __ ] that
I did I watched it I saw a piece of it
too and that's why they're retooling it
as they say in the business they have
fired three of the actors who co-starred
along with Lauren laura Prepon in the
show the title of the show in case you
don't know it's are you there talent
it's me Chelsea I'm sorry are there
vodka it's me Chelsea my bad
they fired Natalie Morales which I'm so
glad cuz I'm a big fan of hers and I
think she deserves better
jo koy is another guy they fired and
angel Moore's his or her name also got
fired they're taking the show in a new
direction NBC says okay they're gonna
try to make it funny this time so we're
gonna see what happens
good luck indeed to be fair though they
do retool you know sitcoms shoot they
look and it's usually a good sign yeah
and they do that we move on I shot a
pilot for Reaper TV shows
Wow where the [ __ ] were you people I
watched every week did you I did that's
I only well missy peregrym wasn't the
original chick in the role it was the
handler right no it was the girl from
Twilight who's not the the girl Ashley
green
no I'm not that girly
Taylor Leary Taylor Lautner no yeah it
was the world that's the girl from
Twilight it's true no it was Nicky read
and she was we shot a whole pilot with
her and then sent in the pilot and the
network picked it up and stuff but
they're like we just want to change this
element we went back and just shot missy
peregrym and put her into the pilot oh
we so it happens they retool all the
time I don't think there's a show that
doesn't go through one more iteration
after pilot season but you know
apparently this they had a work element
on that sitcom and now they're gonna
pull that out that wasn't working
originally the pilot for this show
carrot-top used to sit next to me here
is to show this news and he didn't work
out and we cast kevin better choice gyro
far so good yes sir Sean Connery in the
news this week I thought this was
fascinating apparently before Connery
was Connery he was a struggling actor
like a lot of actors are and he used to
pose at the Edinburgh School of Art he
was a model for painters and they
discovered a until now unknown painting
of Sean Connery as a young man that he
posed for they are putting that painting
on display for the first time ever this
week in Scotland here is a picture of
that painting this is Connery posing for
the artist
today put is that real that's real he
was wearing a little g-string like
that's all he was wearing it looks weird
that looks like could crack walnuts with
my ass cheek I gotta tell you Shawn you
got a powerful physique right there
that song is actually plastic explosions
with the body
here's that mr. mr. Scotland he was a
body those right here who was go back in
a Sean Connery yes what is it Kevin with
a body like that it's not hard to see
how you got [ __ ] Galore you had me stay
in the voice just for that show I'm
sorry Sean you can go back to sleep
this isn't the only time there's been a
point a painting from this art school
discovered of Connery the one in
nineteen I'm sube 2007 I think it was I
brought that one in too
this is the other painting of Connery
this is actually him they ran out of
blue paint Porter my [ __ ] that's why
it's so small look at that [ __ ] trying
to look up my pouch but apparently he
was that quite the nude bottle back in
LA I guess hey it's time for geek news
[Applause]
Kevin McCann's
[Music]
we gotta have them extend that and I had
my [ __ ] out no we don't need any more
[ __ ] out that's just too quick and it's
cute but we needs a little more one more
button that doesn't let's address this
first story Kevin revving Kevin Ralph
and Kevin geek news dragons dragons
let's go to Kiki write the first story
in geek news this week we have to
address it is something that a lot of
people have sent to me and I'm lucky
enough to know the answer to this
question it was all over the internet
this week that Adam West was going to
appear in a cameo in the Dark Knight
Rises the last of the Christopher Nolan
bang
oh my god that would be so sweet
apparently there were witnesses in
Nottingham where they're shooting part
of the movie saying they saw Adam West
in a pub there and family's been around
the set and they think he is filming a
cameo in the final Christopher Nolan
Batman movie then this magazine is
online magazine called floss magazine
tweeted Hollywood bigwigs confirm actor
Adam West will make a cameo in The Dark
Knight Rises this is not true Oh No
really sorry sorry to admit but I
contacted Adam and he said I'm been in
Idaho the whole time making hot dogs
he was barbecuing for the 4th of July I
don't know where they got this rumor but
I'm not doing a cameo I thought that was
like code for [ __ ] his wife no I'm a
knight at home making a hot dog I want
to put this to rest that's not happening
he was not good at least they haven't
offered him anything he doesn't know
where the rumor got started but he's not
doing that be nice why not by not
shooting that whole movie there they're
also gonna be shooting in Pittsburgh and
you're tough so let him let him be in a
[ __ ] shot and let him like to be in
the background or something like that I
busy cooking hot dogs
in Idaho in Idaho while we're talking
about Batman Batman year one why'd you
get sad at the end yes just realized he
was missing it was like I'm making hot
dogs Batman year one the animated film
is watch the trailer it's awesome
scheduled to be released on October the
18th and Eliza Dushku is starring as
Catwoman she's the voice of Catwoman in
that yeah that has been announced today
that there's also an extra solo Catwoman
feature on the DVD so all these DC
Direct DVDs Ralph they tend to do a
feature and then they do a backup
feature with some DC Universe character
in this instance they're like others do
Catwoman that he's a very you worked
with her duck shoot yeah she's cool
she's a really cool lady man Ben
McKenzie of Southland is apparently
Batman in the Batman year one Bryan
Cranston is breaking from Breaking Bad
as Commissioner Gordon okay and Katee
Sackhoff is detective Sarah Essen from
[ __ ] star cast b star g more about man
news four minutes of the Batman live
show have bleak on the internet this
week yeah I'm concerned this is the live
show that's in England it opens on the
19th of this month actually and it's
it's scary oh it's it's like Batman turn
off the dark yes
it's a little it's a little Joel
Schumacher it's a whole lot Joel's
footage what did you expect it's a big
arena show I'd like spected to be not
Joel Schumacher yeah there's a lot of
dancing that's what I was surprised Oh a
lot of dancing and like bring out the
funk bring out the noise kind of [ __ ]
like guys in dayglo hitting sticks on
the ground for a long time yeah yeah I
brought you a little taste of it this is
Batman descending from the ceiling he's
got a little hard time getting his
harness off I noticed that one second
Robin well I know this [ __ ] wire
he's you'll notice he struggles a bit
here's a little taste of the Batman live
show
[Music]
eight
I'll be alright
the only thing you need to worry about
right now
please be joke
The Joker heads yeah I cut that short
all the teeth of the Joker head are
actually henchmen that are hanging from
a pole and they roll out and I started
attacking the Batman yeah I watched this
stoned and I enjoyed it did you yeah but
I imagine if I was in the arena watching
it I'd be like yeah I I think suggest
you stay stone but I want to see it if
it ever comes to this side we're gonna
play in the States in 2012 August 2012
it'll be in northern totally there man
that came I saw I've seen clips online
and as over-the-top it is I mean what
else could it be it can't be like the
brooding Chris Nolan no no if you can't
but I did expect it to be like like a
six flag stunt show that's yeah that's
what I like
yeah it does it looks like Batman
Waterworld yeah Chris Hemsworth will
star as Thor again they just announced
this week they're doing a sequel to for
make my wife's vagina very happy she
well they even me I'd [ __ ] Chris Oh this
dude's delicious you at one point he's
wearing look delicious yeah yeah he's
one point he's wearing these pants dude
they're so low slung you almost saw one
ball pop and the whole time I was gone I
first I was like irritated by how sexy
was then I was like I'd [ __ ] to him
I'd take Mullen here in the mouth
bring me your hammer my teeth or make my
mouth or it's an old joke start it
always pays off it does every time it
likes a poor oral joke or a thorald joke
another adventure Captain America in the
news turns out that paramount and Marvel
the two companies working together on
the new Captain America the First
Avenger movie are going to change the
name for certain countries when it does
does overseas yes
business they allowed a certain turret
every territory overseas they said the
name of the movie is Captain America :
the First Avenger
so they said overseas if you want you
can leave off Captain America and I
believe three countries opted to leave
off Captain America Russia the Ukraine
and South Korea which we'll call it
captain Kim Jong Il apparently captain
ill yeah while we're talking about
Captain America remember the 1990 film
they made with Matt Salinger yes who I
think was the son of Hades Cheney right
yeah yeah that was never released here
in the States
because it's their Red Skull was Italian
yeah he wanted that was I remember one
of the big differences and you're like
he's supposed to be Nazi like we got
close you know
muscley knee Hitler whatever hey Captain
America what are you doing the crazy
shield you so crazy all the time with
the wigs on your head
sit down have a nice slice of pie or
something it's being released finally on
DVD [ __ ] Red Skull Boyardee right
there be released on DVD July 19th
so before you waste your money on that
whole Captain America First Avenger
think right just just get the DVD it's
so much better yeah I brought a little
taste of any case you want to see what
it looks like this is the 1990 Captain
America Matt Salinger and the Italian
red skull look at that costume
[Music]
ow
he says when he catches it he's
basically then playing frisbee that's
the whole entire film ultimate frisbee
bad romance circa 1990 that was like
pretty cool I remember being a comic fan
you didn't have like this summer for
comic book movies back then you waited
10 years for that who never saw it I did
yeah you go to conventions you got
bootlegs on it so we all I remember
gathering to watch that bootleg and the
bootleg of Fantastic Four the Roger
Corman one yeah that was and been like
like you're in a room full of comic book
fans and you've had your high hopes like
maybe somebody will get it right and you
sit there watch it and nobody wants to
be like oh this is terrible yeah so
you're all looking for like the thing
looks good you know he said Yancy Street
that counts
you know nice wings in his head if you
had the wings but yeah it was kind of a
tough set well as we end every show
Kevin of course is obsessed with the
size of Liam Neeson's [ __ ] so we can't
we can't leave here without taking a
look at Liam Neeson's [ __ ] tumblr.com
and seeing what jokes were written this
week by you the Hollywood babble-on
audience as we ask the question how big
is Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
we can't help but wonder how big is Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] I think I told these guys
I do the first one is Edwin so let's get
that yeah right in the way Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big that Liam has to dangle a
carrot in front of it just in order to
get it to move with it keep going in the
voice I like it
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big the opening
credits for Doctor Who were filmed in
his urethra we're cheap you know doctor
who is [ __ ] there's a TARDIS in that
dick Leonie artists in that penis Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that it's in
geosynchronous orbit above the earth and
will be deployed of any asteroids
threaten us Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
that he is the man from Nantucket now we
know Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big he
gets morning redwoods Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big firemen often referred to
their largest hose as the mini Neeson
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big before sex
his women here you unlock this [ __ ] with
the key of imagination beyond it is
another dimension the dimension of sound
a dimension of sight a dimension of mind
you're moving into a [ __ ] of both shadow
and substance famous and ideas you've
just crossed over into Liam Neeson's
[ __ ]
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
God often looks up at it and wonders if
there's something more
well mrs. [ __ ] is so big it doesn't come
it's already here Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big that Wayne Gretzky calls it the
great one Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
that once it caught fire and only the
combined efforts of Paul Newman and
Steve McQueen could put it out Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that he doesn't
wear a [ __ ] ring he wears [ __ ]
suspenders even know what that means I
love that one name akiza's [ __ ] is so
big when he goes swimming in the ocean
chief Brody gets in an argument with the
mayor about closing the beaches Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big he gets free
tickets to Laker games because the Laker
Girls need someone to do the letter k
you're gonna think about that on the
ride home and laugh Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big that he has to contact his
doctor if he has an erection lasting
less than four hours Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big that when he gets a lap dance
he also gets a pole dance Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big it once became trapped
under a boulder he dislodged whilst
hiking in Utah 127 hours later with his
last reserves of strength he valiantly
lifted it out of place with his erection
while he fantasized ironically enough
about Emma Stone Lily's abstract man but
well crafted yeah Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big he doesn't give golden showers he
gives golden hurricanes William Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big that when he masturbates
it's still considered a threesome
and lastly Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
that if you watch Schindler's List
closely you can see Anne Frank writing
her diary from insider ladies and
gentlemen you have a good time tonight
thanks so much for coming out on a
Friday that is Hollywood babble-on for
this week
I am Ralph Garman I'm Kevin Smith babble
the [ __ ] dawg
[Music]
Kevin Smith robbed garment Hollywood
Babylon 5 at the John Lovitz
you